翻訳: Jun Sago
校正: Koichiro YODA
私の今日の話のテーマは
「越境」ですね
越境といっても海外に行くとか
そういう話じゃないんですね
会社とか組織の中で越境する話を
していきたいと思います
ちょっと時間軸をまず遡りまして
当時 と言っても
今もそうなんですけれど
私 ソフトウェアを作る仕事を
やってるんですね
今と違うのは 当時はですね
結構大きな組織に所属していて
５千人から１万人くらいの人が集まる
そういう組織でやってたんですね
ソフトウェア開発だからダメだ
というわけではなくて
大きな組織だと
結構ありがちなのが
お互いに何をやっているか
よく分からないということが
この会社でもあったんですね
そうなると それぞれやっている仕事って
なかなかうまくいかなくて
大小様々 みんな
いろんな問題を抱えながら
実際仕事をしているって
そんな状況だったんですね
で そういう状況の中で
自分がどう思ってたかというと
「俺は悪くない！」
というふうに思ってますね
みんな失敗してるのは ー
うまくいってないのは
環境のせいだと
「私は失敗していたと思う
でも自分のせいじゃない」と
いうふうに思ってたんですね
「きっとまた どっか違うところで
自分が活躍できる場所があって
そこにいつか行ってやろう」と
いうことをずっと考えてたんです
ところが どっか行ってしまう前に
私は事件に遭遇してしまうんですね
その事件というのが
自分が関わってたプロジェクトが
炎上してしまったんですね
「炎上」って言葉は
SNSでも「炎上」っていう
言葉もありますけれども
「制御不能になる」
ということなんですよね
仕事でやってますから
いつまでに何を
やり遂げなきゃいけないという
約束事を果たさなきゃ
いけないんだけれども
炎上プロジェクトでは
それがもう危うくなってしまうと
正直どうなるか分からない
そういう状態なんですね
炎上プロジェクトって
もっとやばくなる状態があって
「デスマーチ」って言葉があります
「死の行進」ですね
耳に聞いただけでやばそうな
感じがすると思うんですけども
もうこうなるとですね
「本当にこれやった方が良いのか？」
「ここまでしてやんなくても
良いんじゃないか？」って
関係者もだんだん薄々
気づいてくるんですけども
それでも 「最初にやったから
とにかくやれ」と
そこに時間も人も
つぎ込んでいって
やり切ることが目的に
なってしまってる
そういう状態のことを
デスマーチと言うんです
で 当然大変ですよ
そんなプロジェクトなんで
僕もこのプロジェクトを
やり遂げた時に
「もうこれ二度とやりたくないな」と
思ったんですね
もう健康に悪いですし
思うのは良いんですけども
炎上プロジェクトっていうのは
結構 日常と隣合わせなんですね
プロジェクトの条件が
ちょっと変わっただけで
仕事ってあっという間に
燃え始めるので
いつも隣合わせなわけですよ
じゃあ すごいマネージャーがいて
私のところに来て
仕事やプロジェクトを整えてくれて
良い感じに助けてくれるかというと
まあ これはただの妄想ですよね
これを待ち望むわけにはいかないと
そのとき初めて気付いたんですよ
「あ！これ俺なんとかしなきゃいけない」
と思ったんですよ
自分で自分のことを
そうじゃないと
このまま時間を先送りにしていって
耐え忍ぶみたいなことを
やったとしても
何も解決しないということに
初めて気付いたんですね
じゃあ「なんとかしたい
仕事を改善していきたい
プロジェクトのやり方を変えたい」
というふうに思ったんだけれども
自分にはそういう術がないし
会社の中にそういうヒントが
あるかというと
みんなトラブってますから
無いわけですよ
で じゃあ「そうなると会社の外に
行くしかない」って思ったんですね
だから 会社の外に出ていって
そこにあるいろんな知見に
触れていこうというふうに思ったんです
この業界の良い所なんですけど
会社を横断して 勉強会とか
カンファレンスとか 結構たくさんあって
「自分がこんなことをして
こんな問題の時にはこうなった」っていう
そういう知見を知れる場っていうのが
結構あるんですね
僕もそういう所に行って
「これは良いな」と
「いろんな良いことが聞ける」と
たしかに「自分の現場に戻った時に
こういうふうにやってみよう」というふうに
思うことがたくさんあったんですね
一方で いろんな良い話を
聞いていくと
どんどん どんどん
自分はモヤモヤしてくるんですよ
なんでモヤモヤしていくかっていうと
「自分は何をやっていたかというと
何もやってないな」ということに
ようやくそこで気付くんですね
この問いが自分の中で
どんどん どんどん
膨らんでくるんですよ
冒頭で言ったように
僕は環境のせいにしていますから
やってないというのは
もう分かっているんです
そこで会社を転職するとかいう前に
まず 自分がいる場所
「会社をちょっとでも良くしよう」
ということを
やってみようというふうに
思ったんですね
ここでその想いを新たにしたんです
何か変化を起こすとか
越境していくっていう人は
大抵そうだと思うんですけれど
何かをやる その活動というのは
大抵１人で始めなきゃいけないですね
それはなんでかっていうと
人っていうのは 何か
「あ！現状は問題がある！」と気付いて
気付くからこそ その次
行動を起こすわけですね
誰も行動を起こしてないということは
誰も気付いてないわけなんですよ
だから 私もこの時
仕事のやり方を変えようという
活動を始めたんだけれども
１人で始めざるを得なかったんですね
もちろん１人だから
周りの人を巻き込んでいきたい
というふうに思うわけですよ
でも どういう反応が
返ってくるか分かってますね
「なんでそんな事
やんなきゃいけないんだ」と
「いつもとなんでそんな違う事を
「面倒くさい 何の為に」と
いろんな質問が寄せられるわけです
まぁ それに答え切れる
わけでもないので
自分でじゃあ１人で
やっていくかってことになる
で １人でやっていくと
だんだん心が荒んでくるんですね
誰も巻き込まれて来ないから
心も折れてくる
となると自分のやってる
活動ってのも
どんどん どんどん
中途半端になって
だんだん途中で終わってしまう
ということによくなってたんですね
で これをまた何とかしたい
というふうに思って
また同じように 会社の中では
特にヒントが無いですから
外にそのヒントを
求めに行くわけなんですね
で あるイベントに参加した時に
そのイベントが自分にとって
すごい変化の大きなきっかけに
なったんですけれども
そのイベントっていうのが
内容ではなくて
帰り道がいつもと違ったんですね
帰り道なので 良い話を聞いて
じゃあ 明日から
自分の現場に戻って
また仕事に向き合おうと
そういうシチュエーションですよ
そこでふと気付いたら
同じ会社に所属してる同僚が
たまたま 一緒の
帰り道にいたんですね
で そのとき
ふと気付いたんですよ
「このイベントに参加してるってことは
この人も同じような問題意識を
持っているんだよな」と
同僚ですから同じように
自分と同じ会社に戻って
「何とかしたいという思いに
駆られて 何とかしようとして
挫けるっていうことをやってるんだよな」
というふうに気付いたんですね
だったら この２人目を
まず巻き込んでみるところから
始めたらどうだろうと
思ったんですね
部署とか会社とか そういう
大きな単位で変えていくというと
なかなか巻き込めなくて
一歩を進めないんだけれども
その２人目 電車で帰ってますけど
「この隣の人を巻き込んで
やれる事からやっていこう」
というふうに思ったんです
そうすると この人っていうのは
僕はその後いろんな越境する活動を
やっていった訳なんですけど
本当に最初の２人目になって
そのとき何を思ったかと言うと
「最悪この人がいればいいや」
って思いをしたんですね
３人目 ４人目っていうのを
巻き込んでいくんだけれども
さっき言ったようにですね
たいてい簡単には
巻き込まれてくれない
１人になると
心が折れてくる訳ですけども
２人目がいたら少なくとも
独りぼっちにはならないですね
だから 心が折れる時間が
無くなるということで
前に進める事が出来る
というふうに言うと
じゃあ 「２人目が
すごい特別な人だったんじゃないか？」
と思われるかもしれませんね
でも 僕は２人目は
実は自分の周りに
いつでもいるでもいるというか
誰もが自分の２人目になるという事に
このとき気付いたんですね
というのは
何か変化を起こすとか
越境するという人は
たいてい背負い込んじゃって
いるんですね 自分で
「よし！俺はやるぞ！」と
「俺が世界を変えてやる！」
くらいのことを思うわけですよ
「みんな俺についてこい」と
「俺が全部やんなきゃいけない」
というふうに思い込んでるんですね
つまり周りが見えてないんですよ
でも というか
そんな状態だと
誰も巻き込まれて
そりゃ くれないですよね
巻き込まれにくいじゃないですか
だから 確かに理想となる所が
遠くにあって
それを忘れずに見据えるんだけども
でも その手元でやるのは
自分に関心を持って
少し集まってきてくれた人たちと
この人たちと何ができるか
っていうのを考える
で 行動を再定義することによって
その越境っていうのは前に進むんだ
ということが気付けたんです
越境っていうのは さっき言ったように
１人から始まることが多い
でも１人で始めるのも
結構良いところあるんですよ
たとえば「明日から朝会をやりたい」
「明日から振り返りをやりたい」
というふうに思ったとして
じゃあ 部署でやるから
10人 20人の合意形成をして
それでようやく明日から始められます
なんてことをやってたら
そんなことをいちいちやってたら
時間がいくらあっても足りないですよね
なのでまず１人で 自分でやる
で 自分のチームの人を
少なくとも巻き込んで
前に進めるということは
やりやすいので
１人というのは
越境をする時には
その最初の一歩としては
実は良いんですよね
でも一方で
そこから先に行こうと思ったら
部署だったり会社とかに
そういう影響を与えようと思ったら
自分１人ではやっぱり難しくて
自分と同じように
旗を振ってくれるような
２人目を見つけないと
どうしようもないですね
２人がいると当然ですけれども
時間も倍になるし
考える頭も動く体も倍になるので
どんどんやれる事が増えるんですね
それによって越境が進むと
で 実際に僕が何をやったかと言うと
その２人目の人と社内で
仕事を改善するための
コミュニティを作ったんですね
そのコミュニティで日夜勉強会をやる
ということを活動として始めたんです
これは２人目がいたからこそ
上手く進みまして
あっと言う間に100人くらい
集まるようなコミュニティになったんです
100人って結構大きな
人数に感じるんですね
だって さっき３人目
４人目を巻き込むのに
なかなか出来ないなと
思ってたぐらいですから
で 100人って言ったときに
反会社的な活動をしている
わけじゃないけれども
誰かが「100人も集めて何やってんだ」
というふうに文句言ってきて
「解散させられたらどうしよう？」とか
そういう事を考えたりするんです
でも そのとき思ったのは
最悪解散させられても良いかと
もう２人目がいるし
この２人目と３人目 ４人目を
巻き込み直すような活動を
また始めたら良いんじゃないか
というふうに思い直して
活動を止めることなく 実際
誰からも止められることもなくて
先へ進む事が出来たんですね
やっていく中で「この活動自体が
会社に閉じこもる必要もないな」
ということに気付いて
じゃあ 業界の中の
コミュニティという位置付けで
活動を続けて行こうということを
今もやっていて
それが２人から始めて
今 ５千人集まるような
コミュニティになっているんですね
この場にはどういう人が
集まっているかというと
社内で越境したい
あるいは会社を飛び出して
違うことをやって行きたい
そういう人が集まっていて
僕が外にヒントを求めに行った時は
こんなコミュニティなかったんだけれども
今だったら５千人がかりで
5,001人目の人に対して
「こういうふうな経験をもとに
こんな事をやってはどうですか？」
というヒントを提供できるような
そんな場所になっていっています
ということで 私の話を
これでまとめたいと思いますけれども
越境というのは１人で始まります
というか １人で始まった方が
良い面もあります
でもそこから先に行くためには
２人目の力が必要で
その時に思って頂きたいのは
変わるスピードっていうのは
人それぞれ違うんだってことなんですね
自分と同じようなスピードで
変わって欲しい
思って欲しい 行動もして欲しいと
思うんですけども
そんなのはですね
人それぞれ違います
それを認めた時に
初めて周りの人を受け止めて
周りの人と一緒に何が出来るんだろうと
きっと考えられるようになるので
そういう考えでもって
皆様もそれぞれ越境っていうのを
進めて頂けたらな
というふうに思っています
今日はありがとうございました
（拍手）